[Music]
it's hard for me to put into words how
much I wanted to move to Minneapolis I
wanted to walk through those doors and
sit at Mary's desk and today I get to do
it that was Oprah Winfrey showing her
talk show audience the impact Mary Tyler
Moore had on her career and I spoke to
an emotional Oprah just minutes after
the news broke about Mary's passing I
don't know other than Barbara Walters of
anybody else in the business who had
more influence on me personally Wow as a
woman growing up or on my career Mary
Tyler Moore was it was it for me when I
was a young reporter in Nashville it was
the thing I did every Saturday night was
watched the Mary Tyler Moore Show and I
wanted to be like her I saw myself in
her I saw so much so that I took a long
time wanted to work in Minneapolis
because I thought Mary worth actually
worked there television set and they put
up a sign that says Minneapolis every
time I would see her at an event or any
occasion I mean really important place
that she held and will continue to hold
forever for me I mean it's the first
time that I can recall a public figure
in recent years passing I mean and we've
lost so many people recently where I
actually sat down and shed tears about
it the moment she surprised you yes
surprised me on that show was a
life-changing moment for many reasons
first of all it's the it's the time I
coined the ugly cry and I went into
double triple overtime ugly cry why do
you think her legacy is going to be her
legacy is going to be every life that
she touched through that show her legacy
is going to be that smile I mean listen
I even did a show I even did this shut
up that show I did a show where I was
trying to imitate
be Mary's point my hair my cap up in the
air remember that I remember that rip
double rip in peace peace peace Mary
Tyler Moore